foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar novel
therapeutic approach to lethal SARS cov2
infection in aged Marine models I'm
Susie Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and brought to you by miltoni
biotech to learn more visit them at
miltonybiotech.com now we encourage you
to participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation I'd now like to welcome our
speaker Dr Jin Zing assistant professor
in the department of microbiology and
Immunology at the center for predictive
medicine at University of Louisville
school of medicine Dr Zhang welcome you
may now begin your presentation sir
thank you Susie thank you for your yeah
nice introduction and it's my pleasure
to get an opportunity to introduce our
work about the south cov2 infection
especially in the mouse models so yeah
let's just start
so
so most of you may have never heard
about coronavirus before this pandemic
but actually the infection of Corona was
in human population can be traced to 1
000 years ago
and around 100 years ago another kurovas
variants called OC 43 which belongs to
the same class just like the South Toby
Mars Kobe and South Kobe 2 was found in
the human population which caused some
flu-like symptoms but it's not severe
more recently another coronavirus
variants called SARS Kobe was reported
in the quantum Province in China in
November 2002 SARS Toby had spread
globally by July 2003
and uh
this chronovirus caused around 10
percent mortality so it's it can cause
very severe diseases but the
transmission of this virus is kind of
limited so it is built after that and no
one knows why it just disappeared like
nothing happens
around 10 years later another kernel was
called Mercury was I didn't isolated
from the spurting of a 16 year old Saudi
Arabian and the list most this Chrono
was was still the
known as the most lethal chronovirus in
the world because it can cause the 30
percent mortality in the hospitalized
patients
and then
we Face the most severe Global pandemic
caused by sasko V2 just like the MERS
and the Stars Kobe it's still a single
strained RNA virus
and here today this pandemic has not
disappeared and we don't know when it
will end but what we know is that it has
caused more than 6 million death in the
whole world and with the more and more
variants occurring from this
a original type of the virus
it looks like the vaccine or the
previous infection can not stop the
spread of the new violence completely
and we hope we hope
it will end as soon as possible
although the disastrophy Murs kovi and
Sasuke V2 all of them were regarded as
transmitted from the bats or from some
other animals by the natural resource to
the human population but these three
different virus can enter the human
cells via the different receptors
such as the human dpp4 and human H2
the entry of this verse into the human
bodies can cause some milder to severe
symptoms of the patients
and another common characteristic of
these three different chronovirus
infection is that in the older
population it can cause severe diseases
so
to find out whether there is some aging
related factors contributing to the
age-related diseases severity caused by
the coronavirus our lab just used animal
model to try to find out the underlying
mechanisms the first thing we did was to
compare the young and middle aged mice
there's responsiveness to the South Kobe
infection because when we start this
project it's we still have no South
Korea is like the almost 20 years ago
so what we did is that
we infected young and middle aged mice
with the South COV and we found that
just like human the middle aged mind
shows very sensitive to the South COV
infection and you can see in this figure
the middle aged mice they all died
within 12 days post-infection while the
young mice just none of this was dead
so we want to know what is the
difference between The Young and the
middle aged mice so we sacrificed some
young and middle aged mice
and they isolate their lung to run the
RNA Michael array and we found that
compared to the young mice the
expression level of poa2g2t in the
middle aged mice was increased
significantly
and the pgd2 which is the downstream
products caused by the
POA to g2d was also increased in the
middle aged mice and less difference
will be
even improve increased
after the infection of the saskovi so it
looks like the po82d and pgd2 contribute
to the age-related diseases severity in
Sarasota infection
now you may ask what is the POA to g2d
and pgd2 so
before we just continue our story let's
let me just give a brief introduction
about a list synonym pathway POA 52t is
a
belong to a forceful lipase super family
and list super family are composed of
the multiple enzymes these enzymes can
hydrolyze that
phospholipids intruder
launching fatty acids and this long-term
fatty acid could be further
how to say catalyzed or organized by the
different enzymes to generate the
multiple different lipid products and uh
including a phd2 prostate gained in D2
pge2 first grinding E2 or and a lot of
other molecules
in our lab we focus on the pgd2
pgd2 plus gending D2 could bind to the
two different receptor in different
human cells and also mouth cells
it can bound to two major receptors dp1
and dp2 the dp2 was mainly expressed in
the T cells and was regarded to induce
the th2 related information such as the
asthma
and
alert reactions
and dp1 mainly expressed in the myeloid
cells The Binding of pgd2 and dp1 can
induce The increased production of CMP
which will lead to the inhibition of the
information and further to decrease the
secretion of the pro-inflammatory
cytokine like the io1 beta and we all
know that i1 beta has been regarded as a
major med-aid contribute to the sasukev
and sasto V2 related diseases
so since the expression level of Poa to
g2d and p2d2 increase with the age and
the South COV also is age-related
diseases so we think that maybe
listening pathway was involved in the
SAS Covey infection related pathogenesis
to clarify their roles we need some
model and we are lucky to find some
animal model
firstly we got a PO a2g2d knockout
device model from our Japanese
collaborators
and when we challenge this POA to g2d
not caramelized and compare them with
the wild type mice we can see in the
left panel
the wild type mice which also marked as
period to do the double positive mice
they were still susceptible to sarcovy
infection but if this scenery this
molecular was not had in the mice they
were resistant to the diesel challenge
of sasko V
consistent with that the virus clearance
was increased in the POA to g2d no
problemize
so Theory to g2d's role was confirmed
and our next question is that whether
dp1 knockout can also show that a
similar phenomena so we got another
knockout mice dp1 the karma is from
another Japanese collaborator
and here in the left handle you may see
that okay it looks like not much
difference in the weight change between
the wire type and the dt1 no compromise
but
you can see in the right panel
the dp1 carbines they provide
a resistance to the visual change of
sasko V compared to the well-timed mice
so taken together least results suggest
that poa2g20 and dp1 synonym May
contribute to the acute saskovy
infection
now let's go back to the pandemic to the
Kobe 19. as we mentioned previously like
most Kobe and SAS Kobe covid-19 is also
a diseases of the elderly
based on the clinical data we find that
if the people was older than the 65
years
the rate of hospitalization and the rate
of death will increase significantly
so we want to know that whether the
po82d and pgd2 also
involved in the human source code V2
infection but before that we need some
animal model
as you may know the normal mice were
resistant to the sasko V two because
this mice was lack of the receptor to
the SAS cov2
in the human the sasko V2 need to enter
the cells via the receptor called human
H2 but mice lack of this reception
so the first thing we need to do is to
create some mice model can be infected
by the sasko B2 the first model created
by our model by our lab is the
885 human H2 model and this model can be
established in any normal mice because
it will adjust the transgenic the human
H2 into the mice
the
benefits of this model is that mice are
sensitized for the sasko V2 infection by
transduction it's a very simple
manipulation and these strings can be
directly assessed without additional
breeding these mice are also useful for
determining the cost factors necessary
for optimal virus clearance and for the
assessing efficacy of vaccines and
therapies such as the convalescent
plasma however this model has a very
major shortcoming this shortcoming is
that this mice model can only develop
very mild diseases after challenged by
the south Kobe 2. so it cannot mimic the
severe case in clinic
who is establish some models for a
severe case
our lab introduced the second model is
called KD model and in this model the
mice will be expressed human is true
after the promoter called K18
as you can see in the right panel
these mice were can develop the mild to
severe diseases based on the different
dose of the virus inoculated
so it can mimic the mild to very severe
diseases and some mice can be killed by
the virus challenge
however this model also has a major
shortcomings because if you want to
investigate the lower of specific
molecule like the puree to g2d and pgd2
you will need to cross mating the KT
mice with the local device and it's very
time consuming and effort consuming and
money consuming
since the pandemic spread so faster we
need some more quick methods
so that's the reason we try to establish
the third model in our lab
which was called Mouse adapted virus
model
and we know that we already have funded
a lot of different variants of the sasko
V2
apart from the original string so in
these different strings
the verse from data in the South Africa
showed a single mutation called
n501y in the spike protein this single
mutation can increase binding Affinity
between the
brass Spike protein and the mouse H2
so it can help the vast answer Mouse
cells
but this entry of the verse can still
not cause the significant diseases in
the mice so our solution is to usage
reverse genetics to introduce this
single mutation into the original source
code V2 wires and then passage this
verse in the publishing Mice from P0 to
30 percentages the briefly the method is
very simple we we just use the mutated
device to infect the
mice and then after two to three days we
will sacrifice the mice and harvest the
lawn to make the homogeneity and use
this homogeneous to
inoculate the next generation of the
mice so after 30 passage in the mice
this virus became very virulent and more
interestingly this verse we also in this
verse we use the single uh sequencing
to identify the mutation in this verse
and we found that just like in human
this passage can favor the more mutation
development in the in in this virus and
all this mutation can be found in the
human susco V2 variants which means that
um actually there's not too many
difference between the human and the
mouse was Passage
so after getting this variance was here
you can see that this verse can kill
both male or female barbershimides and
no matter they are young or old
but
this this verse can only kill the older
B6 mice but not young B6 mice and in in
addition to their uh susceptibility to
reverse change we also found that the
infection of less mice can induce
both the antibod virus specific antibody
and
grass specific T-cell responses and here
we use the peptide pool from the
provided by miltony biotech and we found
that after challenge with the spike
protein peptide and protein peptide and
membrane protein peptide we we can find
that CDA T cells isolated from this mice
can secrete
my expression of interfering gamma and
the list taken together all of these
data suggests that this model can mimic
what happened in the human patient
since we found that the
most adapted device can kill all mice
but not young mice then we got a perfect
model for age-related diseases which can
be also found in the human patient
so with this model we are again use the
POA to g2d no columnized and the dp1
nokomised to test the role of this
signaling pathway in the sastro V2
related diseases
and here you can see that The Knockout
or deficiency of the poet GDP or dp1 can
offer the complete or incomplete
protection on the mice infected by the
south Kobe 2. but of course these mice
are seven to eight month old mice and
for the yamas eight to ten weeks old is
six months labor resistant to the sasko
V2 virus
so here this data suggests that the
poetic Duty and dp1 synodium pathway
could be a potential therapy targets for
the human susco V2 infection especially
in the elderly
consistent with their benefits the
deficiency of the POA to g2d or dp1 will
also decreased the wire load in the
infected alarms and ameliorated the past
Genesis in the land of the mice infected
with South Korea too
now after confirming the benefits of the
pr8g2d and dp1 knockout in this mice
model
the next step is to find out whether we
can get some compounds or some drugs to
targeting at least signaling pathway to
treat the South Korea infections
unfortunately we cannot find the optimal
candidate for targeting POA 22d so we
have only folks on the dp1 targeting
therapy but actually it's not a totally
bad things it's actually some kind of
the good things because it can narrow
the efficacy of these drugs and it will
be more specifically because we know
that
at the downstream of period which you
did not just the pgd2 can be generated
so by working with a company called bio
age we got a compound called aspirin
which is a dp1 antagonist
and the benefits of this drug is that it
has been passed the clinical the phase
one clinical trial because it was
developed several years ago to see some
autoimmune diseases including the
arthritis so it's safe it's ready to use
so
here we just got a compound from the
company and then we designed the
experiments we will in fact mice with
the sasko V2 or susque and then start
the treating start the treatment at the
day two or day 4 posted infection
the reason we choose a later treatment
is to try to mimic the what we found in
the clinic because the generally the
patient infected by the sauce Toby or
susque 2 will underlying the
some like the latency period before the
onset of the symptoms and it will be
doesn't make sense to treat the patient
or treat the mice before the onset of
any symptoms
so we keep the treatment and the outcome
is really exciting it's even beyond our
expectation in this figure you can see
that almost all my three database as
payments were protected from the lethal
challenge of SAS copy 2.
and the treatment of aspirant also
decreased the railroad in the land and
improve the
as Genesis in the law so again
list dp1 Target instruments looks like a
promising candidate for the future
treatment against the South Korea too
but also we want to find out how the dp1
antagonist can be benefited
the sasko V2 infections and we try to
just go through about the listener
Pathway to find the answer the first
thing we did is to try to find another
candidates in this scenery Pathway to
see whether some other molecules also be
involved in the benefits mediated by S
prevalence
so here you can see that from pla to g2d
to pgd2 they need to be
manipulated by an enzyme family called
cox1 and cox2 which has been the cox1
and cox2 inhibitor inhibited has been
widely used to treat the a lot of
diseases like fever like the information
like pain and in the messaging it's a
one of the most representative drugs in
this family so we just use the in the
medicine to treat sasko V2 infection and
we found that okay it looks like it did
not work well
um it's kind of disappointing because
the the simple way the simplest the way
did not solve the problem but it's
understanding it's understandable
because the as I mentioned previously at
the downstream of the POA to g2d
signaling there's a lot of different
lipid products and ptd2 is just one of
them and there's another like a pge2
pgf2 alpha and a lot of things and this
product some of them may be
pro-inflammatory some of them may be
anti-inflammatory so if you block the
Upstream it might not show anything
and also
since the POA to g2d and pgd2 expansion
level will be increased with the Aging
so as paper and when we treat the young
mice
they do not affect the South Kobe
infection in this mice but here I have
to mention that
since the young mice are kind of
resistant to the sasko V2 so late in
knowledge
lately in order to show much severe
diseases as the old mice and here you
can see they only showed a sound like
the milder weight change so here we can
only say that SP brand does not affect
in the young mice in our model but
through the human population the
advocacy need to be investigated in the
future
foreign
we want to know more about the mechanism
and in our previous day studies we found
that the protein pgd2 function with a
small molecular antagonist will enhanced
respiratory dendric cells migration T
Cell responses and the survival in the
sun's coffee infections and we just want
the weather list mechanism also
contribute to the SP parent mediated
benefits
so here we just sustain the respiratory
dendric cells by a
non-specific diet called cfse and then
after infection we found that the
infection will push some of the
respiratory dendric cells through the
trend lymph node to induce the T cell
mediated immune responses and with the
treatment of aspirins
the migration of the The Jig cells from
the respiratory system to the to the
drain lymph node will be increased so it
looks like the increased migration of
Benji cells from lung to the train
leaving node
is contributing to the experience
related
benefits but it's just one of them and
we don't know whether some other factors
can be involved in this process and the
study is still on ongoing
also we found that in abroad the SP
brand treatment will increase the T
cells accumulation and but also
decreased the neutral fuel accumulation
a similar phenomenon could be also found
in the lung and current clinical data
suggest that the news field may play an
important role in the past Genesis media
induced by the sasko V2 so maybe less
mechanism also play a role in the as
different mediated benefits
we also try to find out some other
students and the lung cytokine or
chemical expression to see whether like
the pair lower in the past Genesis of
the South cov2 but yeah the information
are limited it's not like the a huge but
we also saw that the CRP protein and the
io6 and csl1 was decreased with the SP
parent achievement which again suggests
that the dp1 targeting therapy included
mediated the information in caused by
the South Korea tube
and finally after we confirm the role of
this treatment in the sasko V2 we go
back to the South scoby infection model
and we found that
yes this aspirant treatment can not only
work in the sasko V2 it can also work in
the South COV it's not surprising
because the if you still remember in the
in my first several PowerPoints you can
see that the period g2d and dp1 not
caramelized are resistant to the sarcovy
inflection
so in summary here we just show that to
find a solution for the global pandemic
we firstly established some mouse sasko
V2 infection model and then we found
that the knockout of the period g2d and
dp1 could completely or partially rescue
much from the lethal change by the South
Korea or SAS cov2
and then
in the next step we found the dt1
antagonist spent can be used to protect
Mice from lethal change of this
chronovirus infection
the benefits of this this drug was
mediated by the increasing the
lymphocyte and decreasing ISO field
accumulation in the lungs
so so far everything looks perfect and
we found the novel therapy against the
internal rust infection and
[Music]
that's that's perfect but it's not all
the story
in another study carried out by our lab
we found that the periodic deficiency
was not always
beneficial in this model we used the
World type and poh to g2d not columnize
and we established a merge Kobe
infection model in this mice
and in this model we already know that
the Nokia device
they can show the resistance to the
challenge here you can see compare when
we compare the knife HTTP 4 mice
we use the HTTP form not in mice because
the it's a receptor for the most Kobe so
without this receptor mice will be
resistant to the Muscovy infection
so when we compare the knife HTTP mode
the HTTP formice and the naive HTTP 4poa
to g2d not car device we can see that
the period 22 did not commas just like
in South Kobe and sasko V2 in fashion
they were resistant to the most coven
charge
however after they were treated with the
sub research dose of the Muscovy which
means this challenge
will not killed mice but it can favor
the generation of West specific immune
memory in this mice and theoretically
this immune memory can protect Mice from
the
secondary change of the same verse
and here if you compare the knife and
immunized HTTP HTTP formats you can see
that the immunized mice will protect
completely from the charity secondary
challenge
however
if they are knockout no carbonized the
immunized and the knife mice did not
show much difference
when they were challenged with the same
bus again
this state has suggests that the immune
memory looks they are not
good in this local device
so to find out why
we didn't harvest the sun samples from
the wild type and The Knockout mice
and we also use two excluded like the
sensitivity to the infection we also use
the vaccine
to immunize the mice and then challenge
them with their life first and the
result is the same
the non-conomize did not generate the
if effective immune memory against the
second challenge of the most COV
not just the international immunization
but also the IP the intraperitoneal
immunization also could not induce a
good memory in this mice but if it is
improved in the non-conomize so again
this
deficiency caused by the POA to g2d
knockout in the immune memory was more
related with the respiratory
checked immune system which means that
there must be something long in the
airway happened in the non-commites
which resulted in the last efficiency in
the memory generation
since the last specific neutralizing
antibody is the major
weapon used by the host to fight against
the secondary challenge of the same bus
our first step is to compare the
antibody production in this no carbonize
and well-timed mice and here you can see
that especially in the middle aged mice
if they were immunized via the
international
Manner and you can see that the
noconomize cannot induce
efficient
amount
of the neutralizing antibody however in
the Yama is there's no significant
difference between the non-promise and
the wild type mice antibody Titan and if
the mice were treated with IP
immunization the antibody level is also
comparable so again
since the POA to g2t and pgd2 expression
level was increased with the Aging so
all these data suggests that the Aging
in this not carbines
they must be something happened in the
respiratory immune system
to cost the less antibody production
so
since the B cells was the major or you
can say almost the only origin of the
neutralizing antibody so we want to know
that
besides the antibody difference whether
the B cells also show some difference in
this different mice in The Knockout
between nokomised and the wild type mice
and here you can see that
the total B cells and even memory B
cells doesn't show any difference
between a World Cup and The Knockout
mice however The Knockout message show
the less customer sales which is the
major antibody secreting cells and also
germinal Center B cells this terminal
Central B cells are mainly
the region of the plasma cells in the
secondary challenge
so it seems that period Integrity
deficiency doesn't affect the whole B
cell population it just affects the
antibody product producing B cells
so the B cells was in were impaired but
how about the T cells when we compare
the CD4 and cd80 cells in the
narcotomized and the well-timed mice we
found that the period of utility
deficiency will increase the production
of tnf Alpha and io2 but decreased
secretion of io-21 in cd40 cells
and the tnf and R2 are mainly known as
correlated with the information in the
South merge and SAS Covington infection
and io-21 why is the lower of this
cytokinesis
okay if you are familiar with the
Immunology you can you might realize
that
the tendric cells get in the antigen and
then presented through the CD4 T cells
and there's a specific population of
cd40 cells called follicular T cells
the major drawer of list CD4 follicular
T cells was too induced the B cells into
antibody producing B cells and one of
the major similar transfer from the CD4
follicular T cells to the B cells or by
R2 Excel themselves as io21 so io-21 is
a critical low cytokines for the
development of follicular T cells and
also antibody producing B cells
the decreased expression of il-21 by CD4
T cells is correlated with the less
antibody production
so since here we found the deficiency in
the antibody producing B cells and also
the expression level of io21
it's not surprising to find that
the follicular T cells in the pla2g2t no
carbons was dim diminished
after infection
this phenomenon was also funded in the
both in the lung but not in the spring
because in the spring if just like what
we what we did previously if we
immunized the mice while the
intraperitoneal immunization it will not
be affected so it's Airway related
follicular T Cell impairment was found
in the period due to the narcotomize
and to find out whether list deficiency
is T Cell intrinsic on extrinsic we just
isolate the water type cd40 cells and
the cd40 cells from the period due to
the non-caromized and mixture before
transfusion into a wild type mice after
immunization we harvest the sample from
least recipients and we found that both
the T cells from Wild type or
non-carbons can be differentiated into
follicular T cells equally so this
deficiency is not T Cell intrinsic
it's not intrinsic then who payroll
energy in this
events then we go back to the model
in the model CD4 T cells need to be
stimulated by the antigen presented by
the APC and when this 40 30 cells was
generated they need to enter the
germinal center and there they need to
interact with B cells and the density
cells again so you may realize that the
density cells play an important role in
all this process and in our previously
story
we all know that the dangerous cells
migration might be affected by the pl82d
deficiency so everything seems to be
linked together
when we isolated the density cells from
The Knockout and the wild type mice and
compare their responses we found that
the period to g2d deficiency will
resulted in the increased
migration of density cells from the lung
through the Gen lymph node which is not
new because we already know it
in addition to that these density cells
also increase their expression of i1
beta
i1 beta is the
true information recital count as we
mentioned previously and
to find out whether I want data whether
excessive R1 beta will impair the
generation or development of CD4
follicular T cells we established an
individual CD4 follicular T cells the
development model and then we add the
different concentration of i1 beta into
the system and we found that
when we increase the R1 beta in the
cartridge system from 1 to 10 it looks
like it can benefit
the development of CD4
particular T cells however when we
increase
the I want beta from 10 to 50.
nanogram per mule it will significantly
decrease
the CD4 T cells development into
follicular T cells
so all of this
answer
[Music]
the period deficiency increased the
migration of i1 beta producing the three
cells into adrenal lymph node in there
the increased
R1 beta concentration will decrease or
impair the development of CD4 follicular
T cells
and this impaired follicular T cells
development will cause the antibody
producing B cells deficiency
so now to find out to double check our
hypothesis we established a more
complicated model we transferred
dangerous cells from one type or not
atomized and we also treat the
recipients with the anti-i-1 beta
antibody to modify the micro environment
of the of the trend lymph node after
this treatment we found that yes if we
use the adopty transfer of density cells
and also block blocking the R1 beta this
treatment can reverse the antibody
production and the follicular T Cell
development in the recipient mice
and also this phenomenon was not
restricted to the merge cover infection
when we establish the sarcovy infection
model in the H2 human human H2
chestate mice we also compare to the
antibody production and we found that
yes the in the sasko V2 infection the
period knockout also decreased antibody
production
and also in the human because we cannot
use the human to adjust the challenge of
human with the different verse and then
just knock out the theory to g2d in
expression in the human so we use the in
vitro model we Harvest some human pbmc
and then
um
obtain some microphage and the tendric
cells from the myeloid cells in the
peripheral blood of this human patient
and then we challenge this dangerous
cells and microphage with the poly IC or
the most Covey verse and then
to compare whether the knockout of
period g2d with the crisp case 9 or the
Control Plus mid whether they could
modify the
status of these myeloid cells and we
found yes
The Knockout of The Poet g2d by crisp
cas9 system can increase the R1 Beta And
even tierf Alpha secretion in the poly
IC or the immersed Kobe treated
microphage and the density cells
so in summary here we found that the
period 32d and pgd2 actually play a very
complicated role in the immune system
especially in the airway immune system
the period to do the deficiency will
protect the by the mice from the acute
coronovirus infection but it may impact
the generation of words specific
antibodies and follicular T cells in the
middle aged mice
this deficiency this period continuity
deficiency caused antibody and
follicular T Cell deficiency could be
reversed by conjunction of wild type
density cells transferred and io1 beta
protein so the origin factor is still in
the myeloid cells
although we now know about some laws of
the scenery pathway but still we found
more questions need to be answered in
the future like the tool identify the
phd2 and dp1 induced signaling pathway
especially the role of pyrene domain in
the regulation of the information
because we now we know that the pgd2 and
The dp1 Binding will decrease the
information
production but we don't know
what is the mediated law of molecules
which molecule remediate this process
and we also need to illustrate the lower
of cells like the tangric cell microfage
granular size specific
pgd2dp1 signaling pathway in the kernel
wires and influence ours infection and
even some other respiratory bacteria or
fungal infection and we also need to
identify the molecular magnificent
underlying the periods to do the
deficiency mediated modification on the
follicular T cells differentiation
another bunch of questions coming from
the Aging we know that with the Aging
the period that you do the mpgd2
expression will increase but they are
not the soil dancer in aging of course
so we want to identify the Magnesium
underlying engine related lymphopenia
and this failure in the sasko V2
infection we also want to clarify the
impact mediated by the Aging related
Lithuania on the host immune memory to
the sasko V2 infection
and finally since the Aging is not it's
a complicated process and we want to
know whether the change in the
microbiome oxidative stress metabolism
and sentences whether this or whether
this phenomenons discovered in the Aging
will also modulated the host immune
responses to the virus and other
pathogen infection
so finally I would like to thank
my previous lab Stanley parliament's lab
especially to my mentor Dr Sally
permanent he has been working on
chronovirus for more than 30 years and
made a very great and important and
critical efforts
written in our
understanding the passengers and
everything about the chronovirus and
also in this work uh Dr kundli from the
Paul McCray's lab and uh
Dave
's lab also contributed a lot to the
whole story and this work is supported
in part by grants from the NIH
okay I will stop here and uh
um yeah every questions about this uh
story are welcome and yep again thank
you for all real organization and thank
you for your concentration thank you
and thank you Dr Zang for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
so Dr Zane we have some great questions
already here and coming in our first
question from our audience is what is
the mechanisms underlying acaprint midi
mediated effects
okay thank you so uh here actually we
have finished some like the primary
studies I I also showed in the in
several slides here uh it looks like the
first thing is that SB print treatment
will increase the tangent cells
migration from rest from the infected
lungs to the drain lymph node we all
know that when the virus infected people
or the mice the virus derives the
antigen could be engulfed by the dendric
cells and dangerous cells can play as a
cargo to transfer these antigens to the
drain lymph node and where the dangerous
cell will encounter the CD4 T Cell CDA T
cells and then when the energy cells
present this were derived virus derive
the antigen through the T cells which
could be it could induced whereas
specific
CD4 or cdap cells mediated immune
responses and we know that a wireless
specific responses is the best way to
eliminate the
verse without impaired the other
close the tissues so yeah the migration
increased migration of dendrick cells is
one of the mechanism and but also we
found that the treatments can induce the
can
decrease the accumulation of neutrophil
in the plant and also in the lung
infected by the sun's coffee too and
since the neutrophil is has been
regarded as a very important cells in
causing the percentages of the lung so
we we are thinking that that maybe in
this model the news field
decrease system is even more important
mechanism but still we are now still
working on that and we try to clarify it
in the soon future thank you
and thank you for that Dr Zhang our next
question is
our audience member asks whether
pla2g2d hyphen pgd2
hyphen dp1 targeting therapy works on
SARS cov2 variant infection
um it's a great question so uh we
haven't
passed a lot of different variants and
but we believe that yes uh if it works
well in the South Korea II most adapted
was infection is to also work on the
other variants because
this treatment was targeting on host
factors instead of the verse factors so
even it should not be more affected much
by the variants of the SAS cov2 but yeah
of course we we do not have met many
evidences we just try the two or three
variants and the outcome is very
satisfactory yeah
thank you so much we have time for one
more question Dr Zing would pla2 g2d pgd
D2 dp1 targeting therapy work on other
respiratory infections
oh yeah that's another good question so
yeah after we confirmed the benefits of
this treatment on the Sasuke and the
Sasuke V2 we also try to find out
whether it can work on some other
diseases model and the first thing jump
into our brain is the influence of us
because we know that yeah
besides the kernel kernel glass the
influence servers in fashion is another
like the greatest threatened to human
population and every year we need to
take the vaccine and every year the the
the the efficacy of the vaccine might be
different
and
also compared to the chronographs the
influence of us can carry the more
mutant and so it's even harder to cheat
and so we tried we tried a
one
influence our Virus Infection model in
the mice
however the the outcome is not that good
so yeah uh I have to say that in our
model the
this
treatment the Asbury current treatment
did not work well in the influence
surface infection it's kind of
disappointing but the equip represents
another important information is that so
the chronovirus and the influence of us
infections are quite different so maybe
we need to find out some other way or
other
molecules to targeting for the infrasal
virus infection but to some other
respiratory infection we don't know we
would like to give a try and we maybe
know more in
in the future yeah thank you
Dr Zing I want to thank you for your
presentation today do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
uh
[Music]
final comments yes so I think that yeah
there has been a lot human huge humorous
efforts in the whole world that has been
put into the South Kobe 2 infection
investigation and the first thing is
that all scientists all research staff
would like to know how we can
help the the world help the people but
the the things that so sense is not like
the magic we need a more step by step to
find the solution to the problem and the
vaccine is a big step let's let it is so
we hope that besides the vaccine we can
find some other ways like the experience
likely signaling pathway because we know
that the mutation in the rust is always
a problem and we'll try to find another
different angle to solve the problem
like the way targeting at the host
instead of a virus it could be a good
way and as preparing is not the single
the or the only targets the only
potential targets and we believe that
there are there will be more and more
other ways to jumping out and we are we
will be more
plan to to to to find out some other
excellent out our outcome generated by
the other labs and we also we will also
try to find some other
way to yeah fight against the infection
whereas infection
thank you
well I want to thank you again Dr Zhang
for your time and before we go I also
want to thank lab roots and our sponsor
miltony biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast and I want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will be alerting you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye